DALLY DODD THE RAZA EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ.
MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN TELEVOTE PAN
ARTS AND TINO. ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS ARE
GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR WIENER AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR ROTH. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE
PRESIDENT A GRACIOUS GOD. AS WE
CONTINUE THE WORK ENTRUSTED TO
THIS LEGISLATURE. HELP US FIND
COURAGE AND COMFORT. IN THE
WORDS OF AMANDA GORMAN FROM HER
INAUGURAL POEM FOR THE COUNTRY.
HELLO WE CLIMB. WHEN THE DAY
COMES WE ASK OURSELVES WHERE
CAN WE FIND LATE IN THIS NEVER
ENDING SHADE. AND YET THE DAWN
IS OURS WE'RE STRIVING TO FORGE
A UNION WITH PURPOSE LET THE
GLOBE IF NOTHING ELSE SAY THIS
IS TRUE. THAT EVEN AS WE GRIEVE
WE GROW. THAT EVEN AS WE HURTS
WE HOPED. BUT EVEN AS WE TIRED
WE TRIED. THAT WILL FOREVER BE
TIED TOGETHER VICTORIOUS. NOT
BECAUSE WE WILL NEVER AGAIN NO
DEFEATS. BUT BECAUSE WE WILL
NEVER AGAIN SO DIVISION. THAT
IS THE PROMISE COOLEY. THE HELL
WE CLIMB WE WILL NOT MARCH BACK
TO WHAT WAS BUT MOVED TO WHAT
SHALL BE. A COUNTRY THAT IS
BRUISED **** HOLE. WE WILL NOT
BE TURNED AROUND OR INTERRUPTED
BY INTIMIDATION. BECAUSE WE
KNOW OUR INACTION AND INERTIA.
WILL BE THE INHERITANCE OF THE
NEXT GENERATION. OUR BLUNDERS
BECOME THEIR BURDENS BUT ONE
THING IS CERTAIN IF WE MERGE
MERCY WITH MIGHT. AND MIGHT
WITH RIGHTS THAN LOVE BECOMES
OUR LEGACY AND CHANGE OUR
CHILDREN'S BIRTHRIGHT M. AND-
POLITICS I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED. YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY WE
HAVE SENATORS THAT LEE MON AND
STERN PARTICIPATED REMOTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS WELCOME
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOVIE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF MARCH
TWENTY SECOND TO TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE WILL START WITH
SECOND READING MEMBER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY WITH AMENDMENTS THREE OH
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS SEVENTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS FOR FIFTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS SIX EIGHTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS AT ONE OH FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWO
SICKENING UNANIMOUS HEARD THE
SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH ITEM TWELVE SENATOR
BATES WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
LET ME BEGAN WERE ON. FILE ITEM
TWELVE IS A CONFIRMATION OF
DAMASCUS COPY ON OWES TO THE
HORSE RACING BOARD BY HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL
FOUR NINE FIVE AND HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH SEVENTEENTH
ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WILL BE GOING THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME AND PLACING ITEMS
ON CALL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS FIVE BABIES. FIVE BAKER
HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI
BECAUSE I GOTTA. HI CORTESE HI
DOLLY. FIVE DODD. FIVE TORONTO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG. HI HUESO.
HI HER TADO FIVE JONES FIVE
KAMLAGER HI LAYERED I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. AYE
MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN. NIELSEN. NO ACCIONES
VOGUE. HI PAN HI PORTANTINO. I
ROTH HI RUBIO. SKINNER. HI
NUMBER HI FOR CASKEY I WIENER.
HI WILK. THEN REMOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN CENTER BATES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU WILL BE DOING FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF BRANDON DAVIS
TO THE HORSE RACING BOARD. MISS
DAVIS IS PRINCIPAL AT THE
BRANDON DAVIS LAW GROUP A LAW
FIRM SPECIALIZING IN
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER IN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH SEVENTEENTH
ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT. HI BAKER.
FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD HI KAVEH
ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY. FIVE
DODD. HI THE RAZA I EGGMAN. HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG HI HI HUESO. HI
HER TADO. I JONES HI KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA HI WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I CHIRLA BOTH. I CAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I
RUBIO. SKINNER HI NUMBER.
NUMBER NINE FIVE Y. CASKEY I
WIENER. HI WILK HI REMOVE THE
CALL MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR
BATES. YES FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
WINDY MITCHELL TO THE HORSE
RACING BOARD IS MITCHELL WAS
PREVIOUSLY CONFIRMED TO A
PARTIAL TERM ON THE BOARD ON A
THIRTY TWO ZERO VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR LAST YEAR. FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO A FULL TERM
WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SEVENTEENTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS FIVE BABIES. FIVE SECKER
FIVE FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE
ITEM HI CORTES THREE. I DALY.
NO DODD. FIVE TO RAZA HI EGGMAN.
I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
FIVE HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG.
HUESO HI HER TADO FIVE JONES.
NO KAMLAGER HI LAYERED. HI
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
NO MAN. HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
NO OTRO BOTH. PAN. FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO.
SKINNER HI NUMBER- I
FORECASTING AYE WIENER FIVE
WELL. NOW SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN SENATOR
BATES YES THIS IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF TONYA PACHECO
WARNER TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY UNIFIED AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD SHE IS
THE SISTER CO DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HEALTH POLICY
INSTITUTE AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY ANSWERS IN THE SLOT
ON THE BOARD FOR A PUBLIC
MEMBER WHO HAS MEDICAL OR
SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE IN THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF AIR POLLUTION
FOR APPOINTMENT WAS APPROVED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER BATES MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI DECKER. HI FORGES I BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO HI COURTESY HI
DALLY. OR FIVE DODD. HI
TERRAZZA FIVE EGGMAN. I GLAZER
HI. FIVE GROWTH FIVE HERTZBERG
I HUESO. HI HER TADO. HI FIVE
JONES. FIVE KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. FIVE MILLION HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. HI A CHIRLA
VOGUE. HI PAN I PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO. SKINNER HI I'M
BURKE. HI WHY CASKEY HI WIENER.
HI WILK. HI CENTER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM NINETEEN SENATOR BATES.
THIS IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
MERRY JEAN GRIEGO TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD MISCREANT GO HAS BEEN A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF ALL OF HERS PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT. SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SHE SERVED AS A YUBA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR FROM
200-012-2000 SEVENTEEN SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS AYE BATES I BAKER. FIVE
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CORTESE HI DALLY
FIVE DODD. FIVE THE RAZA. HI
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG HI
HUESO. HI FURTADO FIVE JONES.
HI KAMLAGER. HI LAYERED FIVE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
HI MEN. I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN. BUT CHAU BOTH. HI PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE HI
WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE WINNERS
HI WILK HI. REMOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN THERE ARE CHAU
VOEPEL ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. SENATOR OCHO BOTH.
SENATOR CHOI BOGUE ARE YOU
READY TO PRESENT FOLLOW TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE ARE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY BY SENATOR
CHAU OF BOTH RELATIVE TO WOMEN
AND GIRLS IN STEM WEEK. PLEASE
PROCEED. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY DECLARES THE WEEK OF
APRIL FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO APRIL TENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STEM
WEEK. PREPARATION FOR A CAREER
IN SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATHEMATICS CAN
BEGIN AS EARLY AS MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND BECAUSE OF THE DILIGENT
EFFORTS OF EDUCATORS
ADMINISTRATORS AND NONPROFITS
AND ROMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL STEM
COURSES HAVE SOARED AMONG
FEMALE STUDENTS IN RECENT YEARS.
HOWEVER ENCOURAGING FEMALE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN STEM
COURSES MUST CONTINUE BEYOND
THE WALLS OF. MIDDLE SCHOOLS
AND HIGH SCHOOLS. TO CLOSE THE
GENDER GAP THE PERSISTENCE STEM
DEGREES AND CAREERS AND WE MUST
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE OUR YOUNG
WOMEN TO PURSUE REWARDING
CAREERS OPPORTUNITIES IN STEM
FIELDS. IT IS ALSO ESSENTIAL
THAT WE CELEBRATE THE MANY
WOMEN WHO WERE PIONEERS IN STEM
FOR THE TRAIL THE BLAZE FOR ALL
THE WOMEN WHO CAME AFTER THEM
INCLUDING. GRACE HOPPER A
COMPUTER PROGRAMMING PANEER.
AND REAR ADMIRAL IN THE U. S.
NAVY. ROSALIND FRANKLIN A
CHEMIST IN X. RAY
CRYSTALLOGRAPHY FOR WHO MADE A
CRUCIAL CONTRIBUTION TO THE
DISCOVERY OF THE DOUBLE HELIX
STRUCTURE OF DNA. AND CATHERINE
JOHNSON A MATHEMATICIAN WHOSE
CALCULATIONS OF ORBITAL
MECHANICS AS A NASA EMPLOYEE
WERE CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE FIRST AND SUBSEQUENT U. S.
CRUDE SPIKED ACCRUED SPACE
FLIGHTS. S. R. TWENTY WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF WOMEN IN THE STEM FIELD IN
CALIFORNIA AND CALL ON ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO ENCOURAGE AND
CELEBRATE WOMEN WHO PURSUE AN-
AND CAREERS IN STEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER-
TROUBLED MEMBERS I KNOW WE'RE
ALL VERY EXCITED TO BE BACK
FROM OUR RECESS BUT IT IS A
LITTLE HARD TO HEAR UP HERE
WHEN EVERYONE IS CHATTING SO
YOU COULD LIMIT YOUR
CONVERSATION TO WHAT IS
PERTINENT THAT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL. ALL RIGHT ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF YES R. TWENTY L. AS
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS-
WOMEN ARE STILL
UNDERREPRESENTED IN STEM
FIELDS. WHICH IS A SHAME AND
THAT NOT ONLY ARE THESE GREAT
PAYIG JOBS THEY AE HIGHLY
INTERESTING FAR BETTER THAN
MOST DESK JOBS. CAN THEY ARE SO
ESSENTIAL TO OUR EVERYDAY LIVES
IMAGINE IF WE DID NOT HAVE. THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HIDDEN WITHIN
THE FIELD OF GENETICS AND THE
FIELD OF VACCINATION
DEVELOPMENT AND EPIDEMIOLOGY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH WHAT. THIS
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN BAD ENOUGH
pNUMBERS OF PEOPLE IN THOSE
EXPERTISE AND WE WOULD NOT HAVE
HAD VACCINATIONS VACCINATIONS
DEVELOPED AS QUICKLY AS WE DID-
I WAS VERY VERY IMPRESSED TO BE
PART OF THE MARS- THE- CARE
PROPORTION LABORATORY AND NASA
EVENT THAT OUR COLLEAGUE- FROM
PASADENA SET UP FOR US WHERE WE
GOT TO MEET THE WOMEN
SCIENTISTS WHO ARE SO INVOLVED.
IN THE MARS ROVER AND WE KNOW
THAT WOMEN IN STEM FIELDS HAVE
MADE INCREDIBLE ADVANCEMENTS IN
MY DISTRICT ALONE WE JUST HAD
THE RECENT NOBEL PRIZE WINNER-
JENNIFER THERE'D NOT FOR
DIAGNOSTIC- INVENTED CRISPR.
AND IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT THING
FOR ALL OF US TO BE ENCOURAGING
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR YOUNG WOMEN
TO PURSUE STEM FIELDS AND I
GLADLY STAND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. YES SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SANDERS I
TO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. C. R. TWENTY AND- WANT TO
THANK- THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD THAT IS WE
ARE NOW FACING THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND OF COURSE
LOOKING WITH HOPE TOWARDS
VACCINATIONS- SHOULD BE SURE
THAT WE DON'T FORGET THE FACT
THAT IT'S- WOMEN IN STEM WHO
ALSO HELPED HER HELPING US SEE
THIS BRIGHT HORIZONS. IS MICAH
CORBETT. IT IS IT WILL WHO
HELPED US TODAY ONE OF THE
COVER BAXI SACKETT OF SAKE AN
IMMUNOLOGIST YELP. IT'S BEEN AN
ADVOCATE FOR- WOMEN STEM BUT
ALSO HELP US UNDERSTAND BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE COVERED VIRUS
AND OF COURSE. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- WE HAD- ERICA POND
AND- AMONG OTHERS- WHO HAVE LED
THE FIGHT- IN PUBLIC HEALTH WHO
OF COURSE HAVE STEM BACKGROUND
IN TERMS OF FIGHTING AT THIS
PARTICULAR VIRUS SO. EVEN TODAY
WE CAN SEE HOW CRITICAL GETTING
MORE WOMEN IN STEM. IS TO
HELPING ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES
THEY'RE FACING US RIGHT NOW
AND- TONIGHT THANK YOU. BIGGEST
PAN. ANY FOR DISCUSSION OR-
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
WE DO HAVE A FULL HOUSE NOW
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
FIVE BAKER. FIVE FORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A- HIGH COURT
TESTING. HI DALLY I DODD. FIVE
THEY'RE AWESOME HI EGGMAN. HI
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG. HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO. FIVE JONES FIVE KAMLAGER
HI WHERE'D HI LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. FIVE MELINDA'S. FIVE
MILLION FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
HI I TRIED BOTH HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH- HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE AND I
WERE TALKING FIVE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SERVER
CABALLEROMADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR KABBADI OTHER
AN ACT RELATING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CENTER CABALLERO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B.
TWENTY FOUR. WHICH MAKES THE
REVISION TO THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER FORM
TO PROTECT A CHILD'S SCHOOL
MEDICAL AND DENTAL INFORMATION
FROM IN A BROUGH SAID PARENT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THIRD PARTY
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS SCHOOLS
DENTAL OFFICES FOR MEDICAL
OFFICES TO DEVELOP PROTOCOLS
WHEN THEY RECEIVE A COPY OF
SUCH A COURT RESTRAINING ORDER.
IT IS BELIEVED THAT THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAS RAVAGED
OUR COMMUNITIES AT EVEN HIGHER
RATES SINCE THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC PARTICULARLY SINCE THE
STAY AT HOME HOME ORDER WAS
ISSUED LAST YEAR. FOR THOSE IN
AN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP THE
pTHEIR PARTNERS ARE EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS UP 275% OF ABUSED
WOMEN WHO ARE MURDERED. ARE
KILLED AFTER THEY LEAVE THEIR
PARTNERS BILEN PERPETRATORS WHO
MURDER THEIR EX PARTNERS GO TO
GREAT LENGTHS TO TRACK THE
VICTIMS AND ONE STRATEGY IS TO
TRACK THE LOCATION OF THE
SHARED CHILDREN. THIS IS WHY
OBTAINING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER IS VITAL TO
SURVIVORS THE PROTECTIVE ORDERS
REQUIRE THE PERPETRATOR TO
REFRAIN FROM HAVING ANY CONTACT
WITH THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
CHILDREN. CURRENTLY A JUDGE CAN
GRANT A NUMBER OF PROTECTIONS
FOR THE ABUSED PARTY IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER INCLUDING ORDERS THAT
PROTECT THE MEDICAL AND SCHOOL
INFORMATION OF THE SHARE
CHILDREN. HOWEVER WHILE THE
GEORGE JUDGE HAS DISCRETION THE
ACTUAL RESTRAINING ORDER FORM
IT'S NOT CLEAR THEREFORE WHEN
THE PROTECTIVE ORDER IT'S
PRINTED AND GIVEN TO THE
PARTIES IT DOES NOT EXPLICITLY
SLIGHT STATE SAY. BUT SCHOOL
MEDICAL OR DENTAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS SHARE CHILDREN
SHOULD BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL
FROM THE PERPETRATOR. THIS
AMBIGUITY MAKES IT DIFFICULT
LEGALLY FOR A SCHOOL- MEDICAL
DENTAL I. TO ENTER. THERE THERE
BY SB TWENTY FOUR CLARIFIES
THIS BY EDITING THE CURRENT
DOMESTIC RESTRAINING ORDER FORM
TO OFFER BETTER PROTECTION FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND THEIR CHILDREN THANKFULLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE HAS THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND I WANT TO TAKE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SEND
MY DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO
KELLY'S FAMILY. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THEIR STORY
AND IT'S REALLY INTERESTING THE
PERCEPTION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WE OFTEN THINK THAT. IT IS THE
MOST DANGEROUS TIME WHEN A
VICTIM IS IN THE RELATIONSHIP.
BUT KELLY STORY PROVES THAT IS
MORE DANGEROUS WHEN SOMEONE
GETS THE COURAGE TO LEAVE.
THEIR ABUSER. KELLY HAD THE
COURAGE AND GOT OUT OF THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER CHILDREN
HER THREE BOYS AND HE TRACTOR
DALAM. AND SHOT HER IN FRONT OF
HER THREE BOYS. AND THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
OFTEN THINK OF PROTECTING THE
VICTIM WHEN THEY'RE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP AND THIS MEASURE
IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE ALSO
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PROTECT
VICTIMS OUTSIDE THE
RELATIONSHIP. AND SO THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE
STEPS TO ENSURE THAT NOT ONLY
DO WE VALIDATE THAT COURAGE. IT
TOOK TIME TO ANALYZE AND
FINALLY DECIDE TO LEAVE. BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO CONTINUE TO SAY
AFTER THEY LEAVE WHAT CAN WE DO
BETTER VICTIMS DESERVE BETTER
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM MEMBERS THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT
THEIR CAREER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION IT IS A
CAT IT FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT. ZERO IF THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE SENATOR PORTANTINO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND AFTER LEADING TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO RISE PRESENT S. B.
TWO SIXTY NINE THE CREDIT UNION
STATE CHARTER MODERNIZATION
BILL CREDIT UNIONS HAVE THE
OPTION OF BEING EITHER STATE
CHARTERED OR FEDERALLY
CHARTERED ENTITIES BOTH FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENTS
PERIODICALLY UPDATE THEIR
CHARTERS TO STAY COMPETITIVE IN
THEIR APPEAL AND TO CREATE AN
EVEN PLAYING FIELD IN THE DUAL
CHARTER SYSTEM. SB TWO SIXTY
NINE IS THAT UPDATE TO THE
STATE CHARTER FOR CREDIT UNIONS
IT ALLOWS CREDIT UNIONS TO KEEP
UP WITH THE EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE AND BETTER SERVE
THEIR MEMBERS IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION. AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. HI BACKER. HI FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD. I HAVE A
ADAM. HIGH COURT HEAVY HI DALLY
FIVE DODD. HI THERE ASA HI
EGGMAN. FIVE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG FIVE WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. HURTADO HI JONES FIVE
KAMLAGER. LAYERED FIVE LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ FIVE
MILLION FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN.
HI CONTROL OF BOTH I PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. HI RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER FIVE NUMBER NINE
FIVE WACO SCHEME HI WIENER HI
WILK. HI IN REMOVED THE CALL
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR HUESO
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT.
SENATOR HUESO. ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING
TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS. PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU OF
MY PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS A
GOOD BILL HELP TO BRING MORE
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA WE'RE
ALWAYS FIGHTING TO BRING MORE
FEDERAL DOLLARS INTO OUR STATE
AND THIS OF COURSE WILL GO INTO
LOW INCOME HOUSING HOUSING- LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THAT NEED- MORE
ACCESS TO TELEK
TELECOMMUNICATIONS BENEFITS
THIS CLERK. THIS BILL CLARIFIES.
THE TWO PEOPLE WITH THE SAME
ADDRESS CAN EACH OBTAIN A
LIFELINE SUBSCRIPTION AS LONG
AS THEY ARE SEPARATE.
HOUSEHOLDS EXISTING STATE LAW
ONLY PERMITS ONE LIFELINES
PROPOSED SUBSCRIPTION PER
HOUSEHOLD THIS IS IN CONFLICT
WITH FEDERAL POLICY ALREADY SO
THIS BILL. ONLY UP THE LINES
WITH FEDERAL LAW SO THAT WE
COULD BRING MORE OF THESE
BENEFITS INTO OUR FAMILY
HOUSEHOLDS SB THREE NINETY FOUR
CHANGES CALIFORNIA DEFINITION
OF A HOUSEHOLD. TO MATCH THE
ONE ADOPTED BY THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION IN
TWENTY TWELVE. SO I ASK FOR THE
SENATE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
ANSWERED TO SUPPORT OUR WORKING
FAMILIES AND TO BRING. A MORE
FEDERAL DOLLARS INTO OUR STATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS
BEFORE WE MOVED TO DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT EVEN
THOUGH THINGS ARE GETTING
BETTER WITH COVERED NINETEEN
VIRUS. PLEASE PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING WHILE YOU'RE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS COMMON
SENSE MEASURE THAT AFFORDS.
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE TO START OUR PHONE
SERVICE. AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE THE KONCOM SUSPENSE
OF WOMEN WE SHOULD REMEMBER.
THAT IT WAS THE LATE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WHEN MORE THIRTY YEARS
AGO WIENER UNIVERSAL LIFELINE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
SHE WOULD BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF BEING ABLE TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO AFFORDABILITY TO THESE
FAMILIES BECAUSE AS- OUR
CHAIRPERSON STATED A LOT OF
FOLKS CALLED ME GOING THE SAME
ALSO BUT THEY'RE SEPARATE.
UNITS DESPITE LIVING LIVING
UNDER THE SAME ROOF AND THIS
AFFORDS THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS SIZE
FROM THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE.
THANK CENTER BRAD MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
SENATE HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BY JUST SIMPLY THANK A-
THE CENTER FOR HIS COMMENTS
AND- THE COURAGE EVERYONE TO
VOTE YES I HOPE EVERYONE. CAN
JOIN ME IN SEPARATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER
HUESO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI I.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
FIVE BAKER. FIVE FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD HI KAVEH OTHER HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY. I DODD.
FIVE TORONTO FIVE EGGMAN I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO ON FIVE
HER TADO FIVE JONES I KAMLAGER.
LAYERED FIVE LEYVA I REQUIRE.
HI MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NIELSEN. FIVE
A TRUCKLOAD HI PAN HI
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. FIVE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE HI
WAKO SKI I WIENER. I WILK. HI
SENATOR MOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE CENTER CABALLERO. BEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR OH NINE BY SENATOR
CUT BY OTHER AND ACTUALLY IN
THE PHARMACY. ZERO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS IN
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ISSUED A
WAIVER LAST MAY TO ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO ORDER AND IT
MINISTER COVED NINETEEN TESTS
IN THE STATE. UNDER EXISTING
LAW PHARMACISTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE CERTAIN
CLIA WAIVED TESTS. IN AN EFFORT
TO INCREASE CREE DEFICIENCY SB
FOUR OH NINE PROVIDES A MORE
PERMANENT SOLUTION THROUGH
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT
FACILITATE THE AUTHORITY FOR
PHARMACISTS TO PERFORM CLEAR
WAVE KOVIN AN INFLUENZA TESTING
IN A SAFE MANNER. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THOSE IN
MY DISTRICT FACED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN OBTAINING ACCESS
TO TESTING AND VACCINES FROM
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
FAMILIES ARE REQUIRED TO TRAVEL
LONG DISTANCES IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN PRESCRIPTIONS TESTING
AND NOW RECEIVED THEIR
VACCINES. MOST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE AT LEAST ONE
THE PHARMACY THESE LOCATIONS
HAVE BEEN KEY PILLARS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND THROUGHOUT THE
AN EPIDEMIC EPIDEMIC HAVE
SERVED AS LIFELINES TO OUR
RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS LIKE MY DISTRICT FOR
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTH CARE IS DIFFICULT TO
COME BY QUITE FRANKLY. THEY'RE
VERY TRUSTED IN THE COMMUNITY
IT'S CRITICAL TO UTILIZE THIS
RESOURCE AND A HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE OF OUR PHARMACISTS
TO EXPAND MUCH NEEDED ACCESS TO
TESTING IN OUR COMMUNITIES THIS
BILL DOES NOT EXPAND THEIR
SCOPE OFPRACTICE BEYOND THEIR
CURRENT EDUCATIONAL. CENTER
CABALLERO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
FIVE BATES. FIVE BAKER FIVE
PORGES OR FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABRERA HI CORTESE HI DALLY.
FIVE DODD HI THE RAZA HI EGGMAN
HI GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HI HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES. FIVE KAMLAGER.
LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ I MEN FIVE
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. FIVE A TOTAL
OF BOTH. FIVE TEN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT
HI FORECASTING FIVE WIENER.
FIVE WILK I. THEN REMOVE THE
CALL MEMBERS REMOVING OF THE
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE SENATOR-
BURKE AND SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO
BY SENATOR UMBERGRELATIVE TO
BLACK APRIL MEMORIAL MONTH
CENTER OVER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I
HAVE THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING
THE LARGEST VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM.
AND I HAD THE HONOR TO CONTINUE
THE ANNUAL TRADITION OF
RECOGNIZING APRIL AS BLACK
APRIL MEMORIAL MONTH. APRIL
THIRTIETH NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
MARKS THE END OF ONE OF THE
MOST DEVASTATING EPISODES IN
AMERICAN HISTORY THE VIETNAM
WAR- SOME OF US ARE OLD ENOUGH
NAY RECALL THE SCENES OF APRIL
THIRTIETH NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WHERE MARINE HELICOPTERS WERE
EVACUATING. CHILDREN FROM THE
ROOF OF THE AMERICAN EMBASSY.
BLACK APRIL THE TIME OF
MOURNING A TIME REMEMBRANCE NOT
JUST THE LIVES LOST DURING THE
WAR. BUT ALSO THE LIVES THE
VIETNAMESE PEOPLE IN THEIR
HISTORIC STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM
AND HUMAN RIGHTS WHICH
CONTINUES TODAY. THIS
OBSERVANCE WILL SERVE AS A
REMEMBRANCE OF THE TRAGIC LOSS
IN ALSO A CELEBRATION OF THE
VIETNAMESE PEOPLE'S RESILIENCE
AND STRENGTH TO PROSPER IN THE
FACE OF ADVERSITY. AND I'M MORE
WAS A TRAGEDY AND IS A TRAGEDY
NOT ONLY FOR THE VIETNAM.
VIETNAMESE IN THE VIETNAM ERA
VETERANS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN THE WAR IS ALSO ONE
OF GREAT SUFFERING AND LOSS FOR
THE VIETNAMESE CIVILIANS IN THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS ACROSS THE
SEA KNOWN AS BOAT PEOPLE TO
FIND THIS LAND. OF FREEDOM AND
SAFE HAVEN. BITNAMI IS AMERICAN
REFUGEES SOON BECAME PART OF
OUR CULTURE AND WE CAME PART OF
OUR IDENTITY. ACCORDINGTO THE
TO THE UNITED STATES CENSUS
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND VIETNAMESE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF VIETNAMESE
FOUND OF COURSE AN ORANGE
COUNTY ALSO IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
NOT FORGET THIS TRAGEDY AND
KNOWLEDGE THE CONCERNS OF THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS. WHICH
INCLUDE HUMAN RIGHTS RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM DEMOCRACY. AND
PROTECTION AGAINST THREATS OF
AGGRESSION. I BELIEVE IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT THESE SAME
VALUES BE REMEMBERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE DEDICATE
OURSELVES TO THE HUMAN RIGHTS
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM AND
SOVEREIGNTY. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CONTINUE TO SUFFER IN VIETNAM.
THIS RESOLUTION COMMEMORATES
THE LIVES OF OUR SOLDIERS AS
WELL THE NOSE FROM THE REPUBLIC
OF VIETNAM. NONE OF THOSE WHO
SACRIFICE THEIR USE FOR THE
IDEALS OF FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY
AND RECOGNIZE THE CIVILIANS WHO
HAVE BEEN. RESILIENT LEE
OVERCOMING THEIR WAR TRAUMAS
BOTH HERE AND ABROAD. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA WHO HAS
PROSPERED IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY AND HAVE BROUGHT SO
MUCH TO OUR CULTURE AND OUR
ECONOMY. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT THE PEOPLE TO SAY TO
CALIFORNIA SET ASIDE MOMENTS.
TIME EVERY YEAR ON APRIL
THIRTIETH TO REMEMBER THE
SOLDIERS MEDICAL PERSONNEL AND
CIVILIANS OF SACRIFICE THEIR
LIVES. DURING THE VIETNAM WAR
IN PURSUIT OF FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY. THE MONTH OF APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SHALL BE
PROCLAIMED AS A BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH AND WE HOPE.
THIS IS AN ANNUAL TRADITION
THAT MARKS OUR EFFORTS TO
INCREASE JUSTICE AND LIBERTY
FOR THE PEOPLE IN IN A VIETNAM
THANK YOU ORIGINAL VOTE THANK
YOU SENATOR NUMBER MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS- BUT
CO AUTHOR ZERO THREE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I TO MONITOR TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. TWO WHICH
RECOGNIZES BLACK APRIL MEMORIAL
MONTH AND I THINK MY GOOD
FRIENDS TO SANTA ANA FOR BRING
THIS FOR. THIS RESOLUTION NOT
ONLY EDUCATES FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR AMERICAN HISTORY
BUT ALSO ELEVATES AND CREATES
AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR API
AMERICANS TO TELL THEIR STORY.
LISTEN VOICES OF SOUTH
VIETNAMESE THE OCEAN ME AND MOM
AND MANY OTHER SOLDIERS AND
FAMILIES AND REGION'S WHO
HELPED THE U. S. IN THE WAR
THEN BECAME REFUGEES IS
COUNTRY. SOME OF WHOM THE
RECENTLY EVEN HAD TO FACE
DEPORTATION BACK. BECAUSE OF
IMMIGRATION POLICIES. HERE
THEIR EXPERIENCES AND STORIES
ARE PART OF THE AMERICAN STORY
YET THEY ARE BARELY MENTIONED
IN HISTORY BOOKS. FOR MANY
YEARS ATI STORIES HAVE LARGELY
BEEN INVISIBLE THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE OF OUR
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COMMUNITIES. AS
OUR API COMMITTEES DEAL WITH
FEAR ANXIETY WITH THE RISE IN
HATE CRIMES ENCOURAGE YOU TO
REACH OUT TO ASIA PACIFIC
ISLANDERS IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
GET TO KNOW THEM. AND YOU CAN
EVEN TAKE A QUICK DRIVE HERE TO
SOUTH SACRAMENTO WE'RE PROBABLY
HAVE A LITTLE SAIGON DISTRICT.
LEARNED OR STORIES LIFT THEIR
VOICES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOU TO SUPPORT S. C. R. TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I MADE A BIG NOISE
HERE I'M SPEAKING TODAY IS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF S. C. R. TO
PROCLAIM IN THE MONTH OF APRIL
SPROUT BLACK APRIL MEMORIAL
MONTH TO RECOGNIZE THE
COUNTLESS LIVES LOST DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR ERA. THIS YEAR
BLACK APRIL MARKS THE FORTY SIX
YEARS SINCE THE FALL OF SAIGON
AND THE END OF VIETNAM WAR AND
THIS RESOLUTION HONORS AMERICAN
SERVICE THAT WOMEN AND MEN GAVE
IAM VIETNAMESE WHO GAVE THEIR
LIVES FIGHTING FOR FREEDOM IN
VIETNAM. AFTER THE FALL OF
SAIGON HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES FLED
VIETNAM. MANY OF THEM CAME TO
CALIFORNIA 40% OF THIS
COUNTRY'S VIETNAMESE IMMIGRANTS
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME. AND I'M
PROUD ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA ANA. TO REPRESENT
ORANGE COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS. I'M PROUD TO HAVE A
LARGE BODY OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS IN MY DISTRICT. ARE
THEY CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
FREEDOM DEMOCRACY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS IN VIETNAM UNTIL THE
SPACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. HAVE A- THANK YOU FOR
THAT HERMAN CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- ARISES
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. TO IN-
THANK- MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS AND
ANNA FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
FOR THE RESOLVE TO BRING
FORWARD- THIS AND I ALSO
APPRECIATED HIS COMMENTS OF THE
RECOGNITION OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IS HAVING ONE OF THE
LARGEST POPULATIONS OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR IN THE
NATION- IT IS A VERY PROUD
POPULATION OF. VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS WHO- REGULARLY OUT.
THAT FOR OVER A DOZEN YEARS
JUST UNDER- UNITED STATES
INTERVENTION ON THEY- EXECUTED
AND STOOD FOR FOREIGN POLICY
OBJECTIVES ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTRY THE REST THE WORLD.
WITH THEIR LIVES. WITH THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS AS WE ALL
KNOW- BECAME REFUGEES. MOST OF
WHOM LANDED HERE ON OUR SHORES
AND- ALMOST IMMEDIATELY BECAME
PRODUCTIVE. REDUCTIVE RESIDENTS
AND ULTIMATELY CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. FOR THEM THE
GENERATION- WHO FLED VIETNAM
WITH THE FALL OF SAIGON. IT IS
ACTUALLY THE GREATEST
GENERATIONOF VIETNAMESE OR
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS- BECAUSE
OF THEIR RESOLVE TO DRAW A LINE
TO STAND FOR FREEDOM HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DEMOCRACY- AND THEY
DID SO AND SO WITHTHAT- AGAIN-
I URGE SUPPORT OF FOR S. C. R.
TWO AND- I APPRECIATE. OF THE
OFFICE RECOGNITION OF MY
REQUEST TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER CORTESE CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I RISE AS CHAIR OF
MILITARY VETERANS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE ALL THE VETERANS WHO
SERVED DURING THE VIETNAM ERA
I'M SURE RIGHT NOW WE'RE SO
PROUD THAT SHE ARE TRUE- BURKE-
FOR BRINGING THIS TO US BECAUSE
IT IS A RECOGNITION OF NOT ONLY
THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE BUT THE
REFUGEES BUT THE PEOPLE
THEMSELVES THAT HAVE COME TO
ORANGE COUNTY IT JUST EXPANDED.
KNOWLEDGE SKILL FAMILY-
CONSTRUCTION BUSINESS THEY HAVE
ASSIMILATED INTO OUR COUNTRY
AND- THEY HAVE BECOME A PROUD A
GROUP THAT- MUST BE RECOGNIZED
FOR WHAT THEY'VE DONE BUT ALSO
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE OUR
FAMILIES WHO THEY LEFT BEHIND
IF WE LOST FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
AMERICANS IN VIETNAM YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW MANY THEY LOSS OF
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS GOES ON
AND ON SO I'M SO PROUD AND
HONORED TO SUPPORT IF YOU ARE
TOO. AND I URGE AND I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
MEMBERS SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
SUCH KIND OF SUPPORT OF WORDS
WHILE THE CONNECTICUT TIVITY
MAY HAVE SEIZED ON APRIL
THIRTIETH NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
IN VIETNAM THE STRUGGLE CAN
CONTINUES FOR HUMAN RIGHTS FOR
DEMOCRACY- AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
HAVE. EMBRACED THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF VIETNAMESE AMERICANS
IN THE COUNTRY IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT FIGHT
CONTINUES THAT WE HEAR THOSE
VOICES ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR THOSE VOICES
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT
STRUGGLE HIGHER GINGIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR UMBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BATES I BAKER FIVE
FOUR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO HI COURTESY
HI DALLY HI DODD HI THE RAZA.
TORONTO. HI EGGMAN I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROW HI HERTZBERG.
HUESO HI FURTADO I JONES HI
KAMLAGER. LAYERED HI LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ I
MEN FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. HI
A TOTAL OF BOTH HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. HI NUMBER HI WACO
SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK I DIDN'T
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS BEFORE
WE LIFT CALLS FOR READY TO HAVE
A FULL HOUSE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
WILL BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR A JOURNEY MEMORIES WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH SENATOR
BORJAS. SENATOR BORDERS.
SENATOR BORDERS. DID YOU EVER
TURN IN MEMORY PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. SENATOR
BORDERS MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES COLLEAGUES IT IS
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY TO JOURNEY MEMORY FOR
ROBERTS MAKE CAMP WHO PASSED
AWAY ON MARCH FOURTH. BOB WAS
BORN IN FRESNO TO RULE IN
MERRILL SMITH CAMPBELL MAY
TWENTY NINE NINETEEN FORTY ONE.
IN NINETEEN FORTY FIVE BOB'S
FATHER RURAL PURCHASE WARNER
RANCH. PLANTED ON THE RANCH
WERE FORTY ACRES OF PEACHES
WHICH BECAME THE NUCLEUS OF
WHAT WOULD BECOME THIS MAY
CAN'T FAMILY BUSINESS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE BOB WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH POLIO HIS
CONDITION WAS LIFE THREATENING.
HE SPENT SEVERAL MONTHS IN AN
IRON LUNG WHICH IS SET UP IN
THE LIVING ROOM OF HIS PARENTS
RANCH HOME. BOB GRADUATED WITH
HONORS FROM CLOVIS HIGH SCHOOL
IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE. WHO IS
AN AVID HORSEMAN VERY INVOLVED
IN FFA. WHERE YOU HOOK WHERE HE
WORKED HARD FOR HARD WORK LEFT
LED HIM TO WIN SEVERAL LOCAL
AND NATIONAL AWARDS. HE WENT ON
TO ATTEND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO. IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
BOB GRADUATED FROM PRESIDENT
STAY WITH B. S. IN BUSINESS
ECONOMICS AND CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT HIS ALMA MATER WITH
ENDLESS GENEROSITY THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFETIME. THAT SAME YEAR
BOB WAS BY RURAL SIDE AS HE
FOUND ALONE IS ONE OF FROZEN
FOODS AND PURCHASE THE PLANT IN
DOWNTOWN FRESNO. TODAY ONE
FROZEN FOODS IS RUN BY BOB'S
BROTHER BILL SMITH CAMP AND HIS
CHILDREN. FOR MANY YEARS BOB
WORKED TIRELESSLY SIDE BY SIDE
WITH HIS FATHER TO GROW WITH
THE WOMAN COMPANIES. HE WAS A
PATRIOT ANALYSTS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARMY RESERVES. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX BALK MERGING
L. ROBINSON AND THEY STARTED A
FAMILY. BRENT WAS BORN IN SIXTY
EIGHT AND HER DAUGHTER LISA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY. THAT SAME
YEAR WHEN HIS FATHER RAN FOR
STATE SENATE. BOB BEGAN A
LIFELONG INTEREST IN COMMITMENT
TO LOCAL STATE AND NATIONAL
POLITICS. OVER THE DECADES BOG
HAS SUPPORTED IN GIVEN ADVICE
TO MANY CANDIDATES AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. ME INCLUDED. HIS
PASSION FOR GOOD SENSIBLE
POLICY WAS SOUGHT AFTER BY MANY.
AS BOB COULD OFTEN FIND AN
INNOVATIVE SOLUTION TO ANY
PROBLEM. BOB BOB AND I FOUND
IT. UNUSUAL FRENDSHIP IN THE
AREAS OF COOKING. FEW PEOPLE
KNOW THAT BOB WAS AN EXCELLENT
COOK IN ME MORE AT THE-
INSPIRING LEVEL WE WOULD
EXCHANGE RECIPES FROM TIME TO
TIME AND IT WAS ACTUALLY LOADS
OF FUN TO LEARN FROM IT. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE BOB AND
HIS FATHER REQUIRED SAN
FRANCISCO BASED LIONS MAGNUS.
AND MOVED THE COMPANY TO CLOVIS
HE WORKED COUNTLESS HOURS TO
BUILD LINES FROM ITS HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS. IT WAS A TIRELESS
SERVANT TO HIS COMMUNITY. THE
LIST OF BOARDS HE SERVED ON
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE IS TOO
NUMEROUS TO LIST. THE ONES HE
WAS MOST PROUD OF FOR COMMUNITY
REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER CYGNUS
HOSPITAL STANFORD MEDICAL
CENTERS. MEDICAL CARDIO
INSTITUTE THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. FRESNO FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH AT UC
DAVIS. HE GENEROUSLY DONATED TO
NUMEROUS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
VALLEY AND STRONGLY SUPPORTED
THIS BIG CAMP FAMILY HONORS
COLLEGE AT FRESNO STATE WHICH
IS FOUNDED BY HIS PARENTS. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN BOB MARRIED HIS
SECOND WIFE AND ENJOYED
TRAVELING PLAYING GOLF AND
COOKING. IN ADDITION TO RUNNING
A NUMBER OF SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSES BOB WAS ALSO A WELL
KNOWN PHILANTHROPIST WHO
REALIZE THE VALUE OF SUPPORTING
THE COMMUNITY. HE DONATED
GENEROUSLY TO MANY CAUSES
HOSPITALS UNIVERSITIES
NONPROFITS EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THE LIST GOES ON.
HE WAS A THINKER PLANNER IN
ABSOLUTE VISIONARY. HE LOVED
PLANNING TRIPS FOR HIS CHILDREN
COOKING HOLIDAY DINNERS
PLANTING VEGETABLE GARDENS AND
WATCHING HIS GRANDCHILDREN PLAY
SPORTS WAS ALWAYS WELL DRESSED
CLASSY GENTLEMAN INDEED. HE
INSTILLED VALUES IN HIS
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT HIS LEGACY
LIVES ON FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME. BOB IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE AND THAT HIS SON BRENT AND
HIS WIFE LISA. HIS DAUGHTER
LISA AND HER HUSBAND AND- SON
BRANDON. STEPSON MICHAEL AND
STEVEN GRANDCHILDREN EMMA
ROBERT. AND BENNETT IN THE COAL
IN JACK SISTER CAROL COPELAND
AND HER HUSBAND LEE SISTER
SISTER- BETSY AND HER HUSBAND
BOB. RATHER BILL SMITH CAMP AND
HIS WIFE LINDA IN NUMEROUS
NIECES AND NEPHEWS. COLLEAGUES
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT WE EXTEND. WE EXTENDED THE
DEGREE OF RESPECT TO THIS
INDIVIDUAL HAS MADE SUCH A
POWERFUL IMPACT OUR THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN ESPECIALLY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE LOST BY
TYPING IN HIS LEGACY WILL BE
REMEMBERED THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU CENTER
BORDERS PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE WILL BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE STATE
SENATE MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING
TO SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SPOKE
WITH IN THE EAST BAY LOST A
BELOVED COMMUNITY LEADER WITH
THE PASSING OF DOROTHY KING ON
MARCH SEVENTEENTH. THIRTY WAS
THE FOR THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR
WITH OAKLAND YOU'LL KNOW THIS
WAS THE OWNER OF THE FAMOUS
EVERTT AND JONES BARBEQUE. WHO
HAD LOCATIONS NOT ONLY IN JACK
LONDON SQUARE IN OAKLAND BUT
ALSO IN EAST OAKLAND AND
BERKELEY. DOROTHY WAS A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR THE HOMELESS AND A
TIRELESS COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
HER LEADERSHIP AND LOVE FOR
COMMUNITY BUILT EVERTON JONES
BARBECUE INTO A VITAL EAST BAY
FIXTURE. THAT HOSTED
CELEBRITIES ATHLETES ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND HELPED THOUSANDS
OF COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
CAUSES. DOROTHY WAS BORN IN
ALABAMA. HER FAMILY MOVED TO
WEST OAKLAND IS PART OF THE
GREAT MIGRATION SHE GREW UP IN
A COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE WHO TOOK
CARE OF EACH OTHER. DRIVEN BY
HER OWN EXPERIENCE WITH
HOMELESSNESS HE BELIEVED FIRMLY
THAT HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
BUT SHE FOUGHT TIRELESSLY FOR
HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS. HE
OPENED A HOME FOR CHILDREN IN
WOMEN WITH DIGNITY HOUSING WEST
IT OPENS. POLITICIAN HE WAS A
TRAILBLAZER IN ORGANIZING
HOMELESS WOMEN AND CHILDREN TO
TURN ABANDONED HOMES INTO
HOUSING ONCE GETTING ARRESTED
FOR THIS WORK. SHE KICKED DOWN
THE DOOR OF A VACANT HOUSE AND
STAYED THERE UNTIL HARD AGREED
TO GIVE THE BUILDING TO THE
HOMELESS FOR ONE DOLLAR. SHE
WAS ONCE FIRED FROM HER DAY JOB
FOR COMING HERE TO THE STATE
CAPITOL AND LOBBYING. SHE WOULD
TELL YOUNGER GENERATIONS THE
PROBLEM WITH KIDS TODAY IF
YOU'RE TOO AFRAID TO GET
ARRESTED. HE BECAME THE SECOND
GENERATION OWNER OF EVERTON
JONES BARBECUE WHICH FOUND WAS
FOUNDED BY HER MOTHER DOROTHY
EVERETT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. HE TURNED IT INTO A
THRIVING BLUES VENUE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL MUSICIANS AND A HUB FOR
COMMUNITY AND POLITICAL EVENTS.
FOR CUSTOMERS INCLUDED FOR VICE
PRESIDENT CABALLERO. FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON STEPHAN
ARE YOU SURE CURRY MARSHAWN
LYNCH TYRA BANKS MANY OTHERS.
WHEN NEWS THAT THEN CONGRESSMAN
SENATOR BARACK OBAMA WOULD BE
OUR NEXT PRESIDENT SHE BLOCKED
OFF THE WHOLE STREET TO HOST A
BLOCK PARTY. ME MY GLASSES KEEP
FALLING OFF. MASKS. TURNING
JONES WAS THE TO FOR FOUNDRIES
FOR COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE OSCAR GRANT FOUNDATION
STAND FOR EAST BAY ELECTED
OFFICIALS THE ANNUAL HOLIDAY
PARTIES AND POLITICAL
FUNDRAISERS AND- HI MYSELF INTO
FUNDRAISERS BACK EVERTON JONES
FOR JESSE JACKSON OBAMA
FORMALLY FOR BRIEFLY STACEY
ABRAMS THE NATIONAL LAWYERS
GUILD LOCAL DEM CLUBS AND SO
MANY MORE. IN DOROTHY'S VIEW
THE PURPOSE OF EVERTON JONES
WAS TO BE A LAUNCHING PAD FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
FORMERLY HOMELESS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS DOROTHY WOULD PROVIDE.
THESE FOLKS WITH THE HOTEL ROOM
HELPING CLEAN UP AND THEN HIRE
THEM SHE PROVIDED MEALS FOR
DOZENS OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS EVERY NIGHT. AFTER
THE RESTAURANT HAD CLOSE WHEN
ASKED ABOUT HER MOTHER HER
DAUGHTER DARCY MOORE SAID. MY
MOM A COMPASSIONATE A REBEL AND
CAN I SAY BADASS YEAH THAT WAS
MY MOM HER DAUGHTER DOROTHEA
WHITE DESCRIBED DOROTHEA'S A
TRUTH TELLER WITH A KNACK FOR
BEING ABLE TO COMMAND A ROOM
WHERE THEY'RE DISCUSSING HER
BUSINESS POLITICS OR SOCIAL
JUSTICE HER DAUGHTER DIDN'T
NEED A MORE SAID SIMPLY MY MOM
IS FOR THE POPLE HER CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN WILL CONTINUE
TO OPERATE THE RESTAURANTS
DOROTHY IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND JOHN DURING AGAIN-
SISTERS. HER BROTHER GEORGE FOR
FOUR DAUGHTERS FOR TWO SIGNS
HER GRAND CHILDREN AND MANY
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS AS WELL AS
FOR BELOVED YORKSHIRE TERRIER
SAUCY DOROTHY YOU WILL BE
MISSED. THANK YOU CENTERS CAN
BE SURE TO HER NAY FORWARD SO
SHE CAN BE. MEMORIALIZE SENATOR
UMBERG. IN OF A BELOVED
COMMUNITY MEMBER. MISTER BEYOND
CHOI OF SEAL BEACH MISTER CHOI
WAS BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE CITY OF BUSAN KOREA
WAS EXTREMELY TURBULENT TIME IN
KOREA. HE GREW UP IN KOREA AND
EXPERIENCE THE JAPANESE
OCCUPATION THE KOREAN WAR IN
THE FRACTURING OF CREE INTO TWO
SEPARATE COUNTRIES. MIDST OF
THIS TURBULENCE MISTER CHOI WAS
ABLE TO GRADUATE FROM KOREA
UNIVERSITY. AND WORK IN THE
NEWLY MINTED DEMOCRACY.
SPECIALLY IN SEARCH FOR A NEW
LIFE THE UNITED STATES SOMEONE
RECEIVED. AN ACADEMIC
SCHOLARSHIP TO CENTRAL STATE
UNIVERSITY YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY BLACK. HAULAGE
MISTER CHOI HIS FAMILY WOULD
MOVE SEVERAL TIMES BEFORE
FINALLY SETTLING IN SEAL BEACH
EACH NEW HOME. THE CHOICE
GREATER HAPPINESS AND HE BECAME
A LOCAL BUSINESS LEADER AND
FOSTER COMMUNITY AMONG SCREEN
AMERICANS IN ANY COMMUNITY IN
WHICH WE LIVE. HE WAS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER LOCAL KOREAN FILIPINO
CLUBS OF DISSIPATED IN
COMMUNITY FOR KARAOKE GOLF AND
POETRY SUPPORT WHERE MEMBERS
LIKE BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT WE SUPPORT HIS FAMILY.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED AFTER HIS
PASSING WAS UNCONSCIONABLE
AFTER HE PASSED HIS LITTLE A
FIFTY SEVEN YEARS YOUNG YOUNG
CHOI RECEIVED A HATEFUL LETTER.
HATEFUL LETTER SAYING THAT
ASIAN AMERICANS SHOULD NO
LONGER LIVE IN SEAL BEACH I
HATEFUL LETTERS SAYING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY WAS BETTER OFF
WITHOUT AGING AMERICANS. SO
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ONE RECOGNIZES LIFE BUT TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF YOUNG HIS
WIFE IS A MENTION OF FIFTY
SEVEN YEARS NEWS FOR CIVIC
MINDED DAUGHTERS CLAUDIA JUNE
SLOUGH. AND SHE WON. WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE HIS CONTRIBUTION AND
ALSO THEIR CONTRIBUTION
STANDING UP AGAINST THIS
HATEFUL CONDUCT. OF A
MISCREANT. IN OUR COMMUNITY.
PROBABLY THE S. C. JOIN ME IN
THE JOINING IN MEMORY OF THE
SONG. CHOI IN IN SUPPORT OF HIS
FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER AMBERG PLEASE BRING
HUNTING FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
PROPERLY WERE MORE LIKE HIM
HERE IN THE SENATE. MEMBERS WE
ARE PREPARING OUR LST OF BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL SO WE WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU SHORTLY OUR
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM.
TWELVE MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM TWELVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORGES. HI GROWTH. HI RUBIO.
WILK HI. THIRTY SIX KNOWS ONE
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN TWELVE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST FIVE NIELSEN. SAMPLES.
FIVE RUBIO HI. THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
OUT TO FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST NO HERTZBERG. BUT CHAU
BOTH. RUBIO HUESO HI HUESO I
DON'T KNOW HUESO I DIDN'T KNOW.
RUBIO HER TADO I DON'T KNOW.
RUBIO HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH.
RUBIO I DON'T KNOW. NO OKAY.
CABALLERO I'D TO KNOW. DODD I
TO KNOW ROLE. GROVE I DON'T
KNOW WELL. I DON'T KNOW ROTH I
TO KNOW. LASERWRITER NO LASER I
TO KNOW. BAKER. BAKER I TO KNOW.
BATES I DON'T KNOW. BRADFORD I
DO KNOW TO LET IT. ARCHULETA I
TO KNOW NEWMAN. NEWMAN I TO
KNOW. DOES ANY OTHER MEMBER
WANT TO CHANGE YOUR VOTE.
BEFORE WE CLOSE OUT THE ROLE. I
CHAU VOGUE. I TROUBLED NOW. CAN
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO CHANGE YOUR
VOTE BEFORE WE CLOSE THE ROLE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. HI
SIXTEEN KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE
APPOINTMENT FAILS. CENTERS FOR
PURPOSE TO RISE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT MAKE A
MOTION TO RECONSIDER ASK
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
THANK YOU FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
RECONSIDERATION IS EYES THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO.
MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
RUBIO HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED ME TO FILE ITEM
NINETEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. NIELSEN. RUBIO HI
NIELSEN HI. FIVE THREE EIGHT
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING THE FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. KAMLAGER HI
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THE
MOTION IS ADOPTED FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. KAMLAGER HI
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURES ADOPTED FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. KAMLAGER HI
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE ASSES MOVING THE FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD HI
HERTZBERG FIVE KAMLAGER I
MCGUIRE HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER
CORTESE FOR WHAT PURPOSE HEROES
OKAY COMMITTEE PRESIDENT
DELIVER PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT WILL MEET-
IMMEDIATELY UPON THE GERMAN OF
SESSION IN ROOM FOR TWO OR
THREE THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE
LABOR WILL MEET IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE UPON THE ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. WE HAVE
SENATOR ATKINS MIKE PLEASE.
TESTING THERE WE GO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- ALL I WANT TO
SAY IS THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION-
IN ADDITION TO WELCOME BACK-
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY
APRIL EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT NINE AM. THANK YOU ADAM PRO
TEM THE SENATE ILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE
MEMBERS.